When you were 15 years old
what job did you expect to have
as a 30 year old?
—Writer.
—Singer.
Teacher.
I asked this question to colleagues,
but for more than 20 years...
that question has also been asked
to millions of teenagers worldwide.
What job do you expect to be doing at 30?
Lawyer.
—Journalist.
—Managing a production company.
This question is important because
over time it can tell us
how a generation of young people
thinks about the future.
So how do actually 15 year olds answer?
Let's find out.
This visualization shows all the jobs
15 year olds listed
in the year 2000.
The top job was medical doctor,
but there's also athlete...
Decorator, military officer...
Way lower on the list
there are jobs like pharmacist
and real estate agent.
There are so many jobs listed
that researchers tried to simplify it
by clustering the jobs
into even broader categories.
Here's the top ten list for girls.
Nearly half of all kids expected to do
the same ten jobs.
That was more than 20 years ago.
So these kids are now in their mid-30s.
Did their expectations come true?
Not really.
For example, about 11% of girls
and about 5% of boys
expected to be doctors.
But these days, less than 0.5% of
working age people
in the countries where they did this survey
are actually doctors.
In 2018, this question was asked
again to 15 year olds...
and this time to a much bigger group.
Again, the top answers were doctor...
lawyer...
athlete.
And there were a bunch of other
interesting jobs, too.
When researchers simplified this list...
half of all kids expected to do
the same ten jobs again.
But from 2000 to 2018
one thing did change.
In 2000, a portion of kids didn't actually
name a job.
About 14%.
In 2018, that group jumped
to 25%.
Here's why that's a problem.
There's a great piece of research
that tracked thousands of 8th graders
starting in 1988.
They specifically focused on kids
who had science related ambitions
but were just average in math.
They compared that group to kids
who had no science-related ambitions...
but they were high achieving in math.
Turns out the kids with
science-related ambitions...
were far more likely to get
a science or engineering degree...
even though they weren't as good at math.
What this study showed was that ambition,
even at an early age...
plays a huge part in people's
professional outcomes.
Part of why it's so important
is that it helps them plan for the future.
For example
if they expect to have a job that
requires a college degree...
then they should make plans to go to college.
For that reason, the PISA survey
also asks
if kids expect to attend college.
And it found something interesting.
Among the kids who expect
to have a job
that requires a college degree...
1 in 5 had no plans to attend college...
which means they probably
won't be doing the job
they expect to do.
When teens expect
to have a certain job
but they don't plan on getting
the required education or experience
researchers who study career paths
call that misalignment.
One study of Australian teenagers
found that kids who are misaligned at 15
were twice as likely to be unemployed
or not in school at age 25.
Another study tracked
American 15 year olds.
They found that the students who were
aligned or over aligned
which means they plan to get more
than enough education for
their expected job...
These kids had higher wages
throughout their career
compared to misaligned kids.
But researchers who study
these career pathways
have a pretty good idea of things
we can do to help students
think more clearly about their future.
For one, young people need to
explore various careers...
maybe by visiting workplaces.
And it's useful if they've
experienced a workplace
by working part-time
or volunteering.
Those experiences should help them
think about what job they
expect to do
and make plans accordingly.
But most students don't get these opportunities.
Only about 40% of students
in this survey
said they participated in job shadowing
or worksite visits.
And a similar percentage of kids
said they participated in job fairs.
In other words, 15 year olds
aren't getting the support they need
to answer this question.
When we don't do the work of helping kids
think through their futures
it's disadvantaged kids who suffer the most.
Among the most affluent kids
only about 1 in 10 are misaligned.
But among the poorest kids
about 1 in 3 are misaligned.
So we entrench the inequality
that already exists.
This is every kid who answered
the survey in 2018.
The researchers also looked at
which of these jobs are
at risk of automation.
It turns out about 40% of 15 year olds
expect to do a job at risk of automation
in their country.
When you were 15
what did you expect
you would grow up to be?
It gets at this profound question
of who you expect to be...
and what you expect
the world to look like.
Maybe it's not fair to ask
15 year olds this question...
but fair or not, these surveys tell us
they need more help coming up
with their answers.